Ці двоє - справжні зірки YouTube:
Штефані та Еллен Радтке, пасторська пара з німецького міста Айме у федеральній землі Нижня Саксонія.
Наше завдання - об'єднати квір-людей і церкву.
Але єпископ від цього проєкту не в захваті.
Ця історія їхніх стосунків, про яку вони там постійно розповідають… Ну, послухайте, мені все це не потрібно.
Отже: YouTube, церква, село і квір-люди: як це все може поєднати?
Це кріоконтейнер для сперми в нашій машині.
Нам довелося самим його забирати.
А ось я в ліфті зі спермою.
А тепер ми стоїмо тут з позитивним тестом на вагітність.
І дійсно, ця новина, що в мені живе дитина, я стану матір'ю, ми станемо родиною...
Раптово мене охопило нове сильне почуття. Любов до цієї істоти в моєму животі.
Лише за пів року проєкт "Амінь по-іншому" набрав понад 10 тисяч фоловерів на YouTube.
Це робить їх найуспішнішим проєктом нової PR-кампанії протестантської церкви Німеччини у соцмережах.
Зйомки відбуваються у старовинному парафіяльному будинку в Айме.
Організував запис Лукас Шінке з євангелістського церковного радіо.
П'ять місяців тому й уявити собі таке було неможливо.
Але почалася пандемія коронавірусу, церква почала процес дигіталізації,
і от тепер з'являються подібні проєкти, розвивається абсолютно нова форма церкви,
яку раніше неможливо було навіть уявити.
Негативні коментарі в мережі Штефані не хвилюють.
Але недавно критику висловив один з її парафіян. Вона сприймає такі речі близько до серця.
Ви знаєте, що мене вибило з колії?
Цей коментар, що коли я намагаюся говорити не своїм голосом, то виглядаю по-дурному.
Це досі мене не відпускає!
До недавнього часу священниками в Айме завжди були тільки чоловіки.
На стіні позаду вівтаря - галерея попередників.
Три роки тому громаду поставили перед вибором: прийняти пасторську пару лесбійок або змиритися з тим,
що через брак пасторів місце священника ще довго буде залишатися не зайнятим.
І от уже три роки пасторка в Айме - Штефані Радтке.
Остання зустріч з підлітками перед конфірмацією. Перевірка взуття.
Ідіть сюди.
Так, взуття близнюків. Підошви піднімаємо. По черзі піднімаємо.
Окей, окей.
Так, Міко, ти не спортсмен.
Добре.
Більше цінників на підошвах не залишилося.
З взуттям усе було просто. Але тепер починається генеральна репетиція Символу віри.
Черга близнюків Зібнер.
І ви визнаєте віру свою перед громадою?
Вірую в Бога - Отця Всемогутнього, Творця Неба і Землі... прощення гріхів, воскресіння мертвих і вічне життя. Амінь.
Дуже добре. Біжіть, хлопці, біжіть. Що ж, однією турботою менше в списку справ пасторки.
Але далеко не всі так добре вивчили Символ віри. А часу до конфірмації вже майже не залишилося.
Якщо ви не вивчите це напам'ять, то я дійсно завтра все скасую.
Я весь час говорила вам, що читати Символ віри маєте ви. Ви самі повинні це зробити, тут допомогти я вам не зможу.
Той факт, що Штефані Радтке - лесбійка, для хлопців значення не має.
Важливо те, що всі вони можуть домовитися про особисту зустріч з пасторкою.
Причому і місце для спілкування можуть обрати самі. Тож відступати Штефані нікуди.
- Картінг - ну, хлопці, це дійсно круто.
- Так, на таке готовий не кожен.
- Ого, у тебе розмір голови більший за мій!
На парковці перед картінгом - фото з пасторкою на пам'ять - трохи по-іншому.
Тепер ясно, що зі Штеффі можна займатися різними прикольними речами, і вона не буде відразу злитися або відмовлятися.
Я ніколи не сиділа за кермом карта, тож це добре.
І якщо мені 35, це ще не означає, що у мене вже все позаду. Я здатна зробити це знову.
У церкві її дружина Еллен розповідає практикантці, як відбувається обряд причастя.
Це означає, що в даний момент, коли ми стоїмо ось тут попереду,
ми маємо повернутися, розвести руки і потім заспівати парафіянам.
Офіційно Еллен є тільки дружиною пасторки.
Але, оскільки в неї самої є священницький сан, їй дозволено переймати обов'язки своєї дружини Штефані.
Еллен за це не платять. Церква очікує від дружин і чоловіків священиків безкорисливої ​​допомоги.
І проєкт "Амінь по-іншому" - це те, чим обидві пасторки займаються винятково у свій вільний час.
- Ти б, напевно, померла, якби у нас були поліаморні стосунки.
-Може, ти теж!
- Ох, вже це твоє бажання бути неповторною.
-Так. Адже, якби зі мною була сексуальна жінка, ти б вже точно померла.
- Я, до речі, думаю, це багато в чому залежить від нас самих.
І це те, чого ми маємо вчитися все своє життя, щоб зрозуміти, хто ми і що нам потрібно.
У Ганновері - резиденція земельного єпископа. Ральф Майстер для Штеффі та Еллен Радтке - начальство.
І шанувальником проєкту "Амінь по-іншому" він точно не є.
Я маю на увазі, те, що вони роблять, - це не для мене.
У тому сенсі, що я не належу до їхньої класичної цільової аудиторії.
Там є багато речей, які вже після трьох хвилин перегляду змушують мене думати:
"О, ні, знову вони за своє" або "для мене це вже занадто якось безглуздо".
І весь час ця самоіронія або історія їхніх стосунків, про яку вони там постійно розповідають.
Ну, послухайте, мені все це не потрібно...
Але! Для багатьох інших це дійсно цікаво. І, я вважаю, що такою є реальність.
Для пасторської пари канал в YouTube - це свого роду психологічна допомога.
І можливість відкрито говорити про шляхи до власної дитини.
За статистикою кожна п'ята пара не може самостійно народити дитину. Кожна п'ята!
А Церква зберігає мовчання з цього приводу. І є пасторська пара, яка так - пройшла весь цей шлях.
Ми знаємо, як це - тримати в руках негативний тест на вагітність, за який була викладена купа грошей.
І ми - в Церкві - мовчимо, хоча серед нас є ті, хто пережив ці страждання.
Пастирська місія полягає і в тому, щоб дати зрозуміти: гей, ви не самотні! І дати надію: подивіться, у нас це спрацювало.
Розповідати людські історії, в тому числі й історії невдач - це теж благовіщення, саме тому ми цим і займаємося. Щонайменше я.
День конфірмації. Одна з найяскравіших подій церковного року. У підготовці бере участь вся громада.
Ніжки повинні потрапити в ці заглиблення. Ні, не потрапляють. Ні, це не можливо.
- Він все ще хитається, можеш посунути трохи далі?
Три роки тому прихід в Айме прийняв рішення на користь лесбійської пасторській пари.
І парафіяни про це не пошкодували.
Вони чудові пасторки. Для громади це стало справжнім омолодженням.
Від повністю консервативного звичного пастора до чогось сучасного, свіжого, абсолютно нового.
З моменту їхньої появи - у нас переповнені церкви. Я думала: що відбувається?
Нам що доведеться скоро розширюватися?
- Це важко. Тут же два піддони.
- Чотири кути - чотири людини.
- Легко сказати. Так, так, все нормально. Прямо до вівтаря?
І ось починається конфірмаційний марафон.
Ви сказали "так" нашій церкві, вашому Богові, а сказати "так" означає сказати "так" всьому,
і частиною всього цього є причастя, і так прекрасно, що ми можемо святкувати це разом.
Ось Моє тіло, віддане за вас. Їжте цей хліб на спомин про Мене. Тіло Христа віддане за тебе.
За часів корони ми не можемо потиснути один одному руки, але ми можемо зробити так.
І з іншого боку, тепер своєму братові і мені теж. Ісус Христос говорить:
"Я світло цього світу, і хто піде за Мною, той ніколи не буде блукати в пітьмі, і знайде вічне життя".
Отже, ступайте з миром Господнім. Амінь.
У цьому крихітному містечку ми провели тиждень.
І ніхто не сказав про пасторську пару жодного поганого слова. Навіть за очі і не під запис.
Я знаю про це ще зі своєї юності, а також і з більш пізніх часів, коли доводилося ховатися...
І нині я вважаю, що добре, що тепер так.
Одне задоволення бачити її в церкві, як вона проводить служби.
Її партнерка теж відмінно вписується, бере у всьому участь.
Вона така дружня, чуйна, йде людям назустріч, мені вона подобається.
Та й YouTube-канал іде вгору.
А зовсім недавно вони посіли друге місце на конкурсі Facebook Smart Hero Award та виграли приз - 10 тисяч євро.
А тепер ми маємо зробити хвилю. Уууу… Ми щасливі, і навіть на наступний ранок ми ще не можемо цього усвідомити.
Але це правда, про це пишуть газети і там дійсно всі ці статті.
Нам постійно телефонують, люди пишуть нам і радіють разом з нами. Тож це, судячи з усього, дійсно правда.
Серед тих, хто привітав, і єпископ. Нарешті похвала від боса. Ось його вітання у твіттері.
"Амінь по-іншому", наші сердечні вітання! Вітаємо Штеффі та Еллен Радтке.
Відмінний проєкт! Продовжуйте в тому ж дусі.
"Амінь по-іншому" - майже ідеальна історія успіху. Майже?
Я думаю, що найпрекрасніше, чого ми коли-небудь могли б досягти,
так це якщо на нас перестануть дивитися, як на інших. І ми просто будемо жити в Церкви і в світі...
А потім у нас буде канал для літніх про нетримання або про щось ще. Головне, щоб не було слів інший або інші.
- Тобто "Нетримання - Амінь"?
- Так!
Ну, ось у нас і є канал, поки зовсім не посивіємо і не постаріємо.